Instructor: Whenever
you see these three little dots,
it's not just a spread. It could
also be what's called a rest
param. Even though it looks to
be the exact same thing, it's
actually the exact opposite
thing. Let's think about that
for a second. If the ...
spread param takes one thing,
which is an array, and unpacks
it into multiple items, or takes
a string and unpacks it into
multiple items of an array, the
rest param does the exact
opposite. It takes multiple
things and packs it into a
single array. Let's take a look
at an example here. There's
two places where you'll use a
rest param. That is first in a
function, and second in a
destructuring situation. Let's
say we have a function here
called convert currency.
That function is going to take
two things. It's going to take a
rate, and then it's also going
to take a unknown amount of
currency. Maybe it would be
amount one, amount two, amount
three, amount four, etc., etc.
Here we don't really know how
many the person is going to pass.
Now you might be saying, "That's
fine, just don't do it all and
use the arguments object." The
problem here is that we actually
want the first thing to be the
rate, and then the rest of them
to be the amounts that the
person would like to convert.
Let's see how we would run it
here. We say convert
currency, and we want to convert
at $1.54 per dollar. Then we
want to pass a whole bunch of
dollar values that we have.
Maybe we have $10, maybe we have $
23, maybe we have $52, maybe a $
1, and then another $56. Those
amounts are being passed, and
there's no real good way for us
to do that, until now that we
have the rest param. What we
can do is we can say ...amounts,
and it's going to do exactly
what you think it would do. It's
going to grab the rest of them.
Let's take a quick look at what
we have. We're going to console.
log rate and amounts. Now what
do we have here? The first
one is just the value as it was
passed in. But because we did a
rest param here, what it does is
it captures everything else that
gets passed to this function. If
I run it again with only one
item, you'll see here we get 1.
54 in an array of everything,
here we get 1.54 in just an
array of one actual item.
That's really handy because we
can do something like this. We
could return the amounts, and we
could just map over that, and we
take the amount and return the
amount times the rate. Const
amounts equals and console.log
that amounts right here. We
should be able to get an array
of all of those converted
currency values. That's
where it is. You can use as many
possible pre ones. If you had
rate, and tax, and tip, and then
amounts, what that would give us
is three things. Let's take a
look here. Console.log rate tax
tip amounts. One, two, three.
Rate, tax, tip, and then the
rest of them are put into an
array here. Open that up,
you'll notice that it is a true
array. It's not an arguments
object, it's not something weird,
it's not array-ish. It's a true
array. That's the first use case
for when you would use a rest
param. Second use case is
when you are destructuring. Now
we took a look at this a whole
bunch of videos ago, but let's
take a look at a example again.
Let's say that we have an array
of data that came from a jogging
application. We'll have const
runner equals, and they just
gave us an array of actual data.
The first one is their name, the
second one is their runner ID,
and then from there on out it's
just information about how many
kilometers they have run. Maybe
5.5 km, 5 km, 3 km, 6 km,
and a big one, 35 km. That's
maybe some comma separated data
that we would get in. We want to
destructure this data in,
assuming the first item will be
the name, the second item will
be the runner ID, and then the
rest of the items are going to
be a log of all their runs.
We could destructure that data
by doing this. We'll say const
square brackets, name, ID, and
we want to say runs here, but
let's try without the rest and
see what we have. Equals runner.
We'll take all three of those
variables and console.log them.
We see Wes Bos, 1, 2, 3, and 5.5,
because that's just grabbing the
third thing. What if I wanted
the rest of them? We do ...runs,
and that should bundle up
everything that is left in the
array as you are destructuring
it. Everything to the end will
be bundled up into an array here
and you could loop over that and
use that data. We looked at
another example earlier, where
we had a team array. The first
person would be the captain,
second person would be the
assistant captain, and then the
rest of the people would be on
the actual team. We could do
something like this. Const
captain assistant, and then the
rest of the...we'll just call
them players. We do ... and that
should give us array of Lux,
Sheena and Kelly = team. Take
those variables now, console.log
them. You see we get Wes as the
first one, Kate as the second
one, and then the rest of them
are put into an array of players.
Not something you're going to
use all the time, but it really
helps you when you don't have to
do any splicing or counting on
indexes. You can just say, "Just
give me the rest," for either a
function definition, or for when
I'm destructuring an array.